you have interviewed a ton of
Fascinating People from the FBI CIA and
many many other walks of life but you
also have had people who have been on
the other side what is good in bed
though too you know in any system
there's always outliers and stuff it's
tough because you know people get one
life and if you're the one caught in the
middle of it well I'm too [__] bad
man I gotta I gotta ask after all that
like when you first get the whiff of of
that FTX news what's going through your
mind
all right guys bang bang I've got Julian
here with me uh you have interviewed a
ton of Fascinating People from the FBI
CIA and many many other walks of life
what is it that draws you to talking to
these people who come from uh just these
different organizations who all seem to
be somewhat critical of their past
organizations but also seem to be really
prideful in the work that they did while
they were within the organization yeah
so it's a great question starting things
off heavy here but I mean yeah there's
definitely been an angle of my podcast
where we talk with say like government
agencies it's it's a piece of it I talk
with all different types of people and
they all interest me in different ways
but the rude answer is that like
everyone else if I'm interested in it
I'll talk with them and then as far as
like what criticism they're willing to
give that kind of blows me away
sometimes you could get a guy in there
like Andy Bustamante who it's really
really impressive and he's not allowed
to say yet publicly where he was
stationed but I think when he went he's
on like every podcast now but I think
when he went on Patrick Bet David
the way he put it was I'm not allowed to
say where I was stationed but I am
allowed to say it was Asia I speak
Chinese and Thai so you do the math
right so you can kind of figure out this
guy was in an important part of the
world and he is very very
like some commentersal joke like this
guy's the [__] PR man for the CIA or
something so he he's very he speaks up
to the organization in a lot of ways but
even he will come in and say some things
about like his own life and his own
priorities for his family where it's
like well that's definitely not a part
of the old Playbook here and I think
really what it what it boils down to is
I mean you know it well you've sat down
with what over a thousand people now
overall it's like you sit with people
for a long time especially like maybe
not some of the earlier ones you did
where it was only 20 minutes or
something like that but as you went
along and started doing long form
people will open up you know and
I always want to make sure that like I'm
protective of them I guess I don't want
them ever feeling like oh I went into
stuff I didn't want to go into but we
really haven't had that problem what I
find is that people like Andy people
like Jim when they give some of that
criticism
they'll afterwards they're like you know
what that was fair and they're cool with
it and Andy is a former CIA uh spy
essentially covert spot and allegedly
was and Jim uh is a former FBI agent
right among other Jim has a really
interesting resume Jim diorio he was
West Point Army Ranger as an Army Ranger
he did a lot of undercover work which is
as he explains it very different in the
Army where you go undercover you're
going there to kill the people it's not
like oh get a get an asset or whatever
and so he did that for eight years and
then went to the FBI where he was 11
years on and off undercover some really
long jobs some quick jobs but became
also a case officer through that time
and then ended up being one of the
bureau's lead International
interrogators so when they had a serious
problem somewhere around the world
they'd call in Jim and he'd be the guy
so like when the Captain Phillips thing
was going down he was brought in to be
on the other boat if needed things like
that but he's just got a very
he's had a quite of a ride over the last
30 years or so what are the
commonalities between somebody like a
CIA spy somebody who is an FBI
negotiator uh and then like I'll call
like an average citizen right after you
sit down you talk to these people like
can you identify things that they
actually share as qualities
well let's start with the FBI CIA thing
so there's a lot of differences that
I've read about over the years before I
knew a lot of these guys between not
that I know like a lot of them at this
point but you know the ones that I do
know it's like
there are differences between CIA and
FBI and if you really want to start with
it it's the fact that there's
long-standing rivalries between the two
FBI historically were the cops CIA
historically were the spies makes sense
post 911 started to change that so what
I find is you're more likely to find now
CIA agents and FBI agents who will speak
highly of the other organization still
plenty who don't but they're kind of
working on a lot of the same things
that's not
let me say that better it's not that
they're working on the same thing all
the time but
you see the CIA start to put more of an
emphasis on China per se
you'll see the FBI start doing that too
because the FBI looks at you know
policing interests here but our
interests are also affected in other
places so it's like a really it's a it's
a fine line but you know the the the
cultures I'm sure are different and
they're also both from what I understand
have been told they're kind of changing
at both of those places too the FBI is
the one where it really depends who you
talk to my takeaway there from from what
people told me is that it really depends
on the office you're in at the FBI
there's different offices that have
different philosophies I don't really
know but
it's hard to explain but once you sit
down with them you can see the things
that Drew these guys to say the CIA and
the FBI but you also see how like their
General demeanor and approach is
different Jim and Andy are interesting
because they now work together a little
bit that was kind of cool together
so Andy does
for lack of a better way of putting it
he does like high level Executive
coaching and and Consulting for like
Fortune 100s and Fortune 500s as well as
some stuff for like private high net
worth individuals Jim does a lot of
security stuff he's kind of like a glue
guy he says my only rule is I don't kill
if it's on American soil if it's
somewhere else we'll figure that out but
I don't know if he's serious about that
but never know maybe but he and Andy
obviously have a lot of circles where
it's like Andy could be running with
this company and want to do
jobs A and B but he doesn't want to do c
and d and Jim wants to do c and d and
now like oh we got FBI CIA say less
that's kind of how people are but yeah
like they work really well together and
I think that's because
you know without them telling me this
just just my take away
they both have had to
they both have done serious covert work
in different settings and they both have
had to
take some lives and and they don't take
that lightly at all and and that's you
know
it's not something I've ever had to do I
I can't yeah I can't really relate to
that other than what they try to tell me
yeah what's fascinating about uh many of
the conversations you've had is that you
had FBI and CIA agents uh and not just
any I mean these are covert operators
and interrogators and things like that
but you also had people who have been on
the other side of uh maybe the battle
the the good guys versus bad guys the
cops versus the robbers you know what is
good and bad though too you know yes so
Matthew Cox is uh one of at one point
he's one of the FBI's Most Wanted fraud
uh suspects yeah and then also uh you
had a guy who was a billionaire at the
time during the 2008 2009 financial
crisis and I think he actually is the
only person to come out of the financial
crisis that actually went to jail for a
period of time
so the better way to say it is that
really no one who perpetuated that fraud
in 2008 ever went to jail okay because
by the way and I'll explain the
background of Raj rajaratnam who you're
talking about but he had nothing to do
with that and that's not what he was
charged with right Raj is actually a guy
that you need to sit with okay because
there's some language there that you
know I worked on Wall Street you and I
both know that but like you know you're
a lot longer in the tooth as far as like
knowledge of this stuff than I ever got
a chance to be and Raj was
to put it mildly you know he's probably
one of the 10 best investors to ever
live and he was charged in the end of
2009 with insider trading he ran a hedge
fund in New York and for all the guys
you know who are on Wall Street during
that period I'm sure they say a lot of
the same things that the guys I know say
to me and that is that especially
whether it be in hedge funds or in some
of the on the trading floors and stuff
like that there's always some things
that come through you're doing your job
every day things slip on the phone
whatever
that's not what they accused this guy of
they accused Raj rajaratnam
of being in charge of this Mass
conspiracy on Wall Street like you know
the show billions it's basically what
they were saying he was doing like where
you're meeting people in a back alley or
a pizza place and being like give me the
[__] numbers on on this company
that's not at all what he did and I had
the funny thing is I had followed that
case I was like a freshman in high
school or something or maybe not even in
high school yet but I was interested in
in that case because it was such a big
deal at the time and he got found guilty
he got the longest sentence I believe
still to this day ever for insider
trading and I thought he was guilty
because you know I read the news I read
the Wall Street Journal all this stuff
how long was the sentence
this sentence was for 11 years he ended
up doing seven and a half Kim Kardashian
got him out of prison like he the last
half a year he was going to do
pre-parole he got to do at home because
of Kim Kardashian's really shout out to
Kim but I got connected to him through a
fan of my show who reached out and said
do you know who Raj is I said [__] yeah
I know who Raj is he's like what do you
think of that I'm like I mean I thought
he was guilty but I thought you know I
think insider trading is not a good
thing I just thought it was kind of
crazy like how much they played this up
and he goes okay okay that's that's fair
or whatever but I I think he'd be really
good to do a podcast with him and then
we started talking about I said well
what's your opinion and he went through
the whole thing and and he's like you
know I'm a friend so I'm obviously like
I'm a little biased but no I I think he
was innocent as all hell and this really
got my brain turning because I'm like
we should this was like a big case like
are you sure this guy was like Innocent
but what it what had happened was and
part of the what you brought this up for
was
the southern district of New York
didn't want to go after the cases for
the 2008 crisis like the actual fraud on
the mortgages and everything because
they were complex and they were not
guaranteed wins so they said we need
something to make it a guaranteed win
and they hired a PR department
they had like I forget the exact number
so I won't say it but they had more than
several people whose sole job was media
relations working for the Southern
Southern District of New York and they
went after hedge funds to sell the hedge
funds as cracking down on Wall Street
now is there some bad [__] that happens
to hedge funds absolutely should they go
after that absolutely but they sold it
as we're getting all the crooks who did
it in 08 and that's not what they were
doing so when I was talking with Raj's
friend I said you know
I want to talk to him first as well like
like meet him on Zoom or something
quickly but you know let's let's wait a
few weeks on this I want to do a deep
dive on this whole thing
and so I started going through
everything and I read his book that he
wrote by hand in prison as well which of
course is biased towards him you have to
take that into account but then I
started looking at some of the court
documents
my dad who's a civil litigator not a
criminal attorney but I had him look at
a couple things too
and I started to kind of click to me
with some of the stuff they did in the
southern district of New York during
that era and I'm like holy [__] like
I I don't think this guy did this you
know do I think that there was probably
something somewhere where there were
some trades where there were information
sure but there was what one thing I was
damn sure of was I'm like I don't think
there was any Criminal Intent here but I
want to know that when I sit down with
them so we we sat down and did a podcast
he came down like for the day you know
he was there like the whole day
awesome dude
one of the most humble people I've ever
met you know you've sat with a lot of
people who have a lot of money right
you've sat with some serious
billionaires and stuff through my last
job I did sit with a lot of people who
have a lot of money and plenty of them
were good people but you know my
experience is that
there's kind of a thing when you're
sitting across from someone who maybe is
worth a billion or 600 million something
like that where when you look them in
the eyes it's like
you're you and I'm me you know what I
mean like there's just a little thing
there and there was none of that with
him he was as cool as a cucumber and
what really did it for me was
one of the many things wrong with his
case was the government had to rely on
Witnesses which to an extent like I
understand this is a part of the process
you have to do that but it's a tough
thing when you have to turn people who
are corrupt and the main witness who is
for all intents and purposes responsible
for him being behind bars
that witness in addition to actually
being like a really bad dude for reasons
that didn't have to do with insider
trading or anything like that
that guy was called to testify
two and a half years later in Raj's
brother's trial
so the last day
of the statute of limitations raja's
brother who was not like the number two
or you know it was like a VP or
something Raj's brother is in Brazil and
the southern district decides we're
going to charge him because he won't
come back to America now because they're
originally from Sri Lanka he's like
he'll hopefully we'll get a w this will
be great
dude goes [__] that gets on the first
flight back to New York
so the brother lands in New York now
mind you Raj has now been in prison for
almost two years at this point guilty of
the 14 counts they charged the brother
with I think I want to say it was eight
counts but maybe we can check that it
was you know it was a number of counts
and they were all the same traits the
Raj was charged with
this time that witness though comes into
court
and he testifies the opposite
because his probation was over the
government had already paraded him out
there as like a Neil I think his name
was Anil Kumar and Neil Kumar was one of
the best Witnesses we've ever dealt with
whatever and this was a much smaller
case because the brother was smaller
potatoes and so the prosecution was like
stunned when he testifies the opposite
like oh no they didn't know about this
they didn't know about that and they
just they didn't charge the guy with
perjury nothing they quietly Let It Go
his brother was found not guilty in
three hours which means the jury didn't
even order pizza right I mean this is a
financials case you usually spend like
two days as a jury just looking at the
trades before you even start talking
about the case and so Raj I saw this
online well we're researching this and
my dad was like what the [__] looking at
it Raj then files an appeal obviously
like uh hey your witness just testified
the opposite in court they found me
guilty
I think I need a new case here
toss that
and I just watched this system then I
find the same year his driver
who had been the driver for the family
for a few years who would drive his wife
to prison to visit him
there's a big story in the New York Post
that says the driver is given the
details on like Raj living as King in
prison and all this and how he smuggles
in stuff for Raj to get favors
they don't report the fact that that and
and because you filed a lawsuit they
don't report that fact as coming three
weeks after the driver beat the [__] out
of his wife almost to death
and of course got fired by Raj's wife
so now suddenly you know he claims all
this stuff and they just I watched how
they painted this guy and then I met him
and now I know him now he's a friend too
and of course I may be a little biased
on the situation but I wasn't when I
started I mean when I talked to him on
Zoom before we ever like he came down
and did the podcast he asked me Point
Blank he said well I heard you had
followed the case what'd you think and I
said I thought you were guilty like I
was very upfront about it and he was
like no problem you know whatever but
afterwards you know I was like there's
probably a few things that literally
every hedge fund was technically guilty
of front running trades abso [__]
lutely you know stuff like that that
that happened but when it comes to like
what he was accused of and all that I
was like wow did he ever admit to doing
any of it not only did he not admit it
the second the show billions to bring
that up again
to be very specific that is as it's been
alleged and I think maybe Andrew Ross
Sorkin has confirmed this but I'm not
positive
that's based on the southern districts
chasing of Steve Cohen
Steve Cohen is probably the best
investor ever on Wall Street and
you know Raj was one of the best he
obviously ran in circles with Steve
the southern district never wanted Raj
they wanted Steve
and if Steve did anything wrong
Raj didn't know about it that's what he
says at least and so when he was taken
down for questioning when he was first
arrested they made they spent like over
it was in seven figures they spent to
arrest him like they had duck boats in
the river on the East River in New York
this guy's like you know
the 50 year old Wall Street guy he's not
exactly running 12 miles away from cops
right yes or swimming across the river
yeah yeah I don't think Raj is like a
great swimmer that's just I don't know
just how I look at it doesn't have a
secret submarine ready no so you know
they have the cameras out there
everything and they take them downtown
the guy
answered questions with them without a
lawyer
he was so perplexed by this like he
legitimately was like
what what do you mean he didn't know
what he was arrested for until they took
him down which is perfectly legal they
don't have to mirandize you until you
get down there and all that but he
answered questions without a lawyer and
he was like they said listen
we got you on these wire Taps and
everything because he was the first
wiretap case in Wall Street history
and they're like
if you talk to us now like you know this
isn't good for you but you won't go to
prison you do the right thing you answer
on some other guys you can go home to
your wife you're worth billions of
dollars like you're still gonna be worth
billions of dollars like call it a day
we got you
and he said no I'm I'm innocent I don't
and I don't know anything about other
people I run one company he didn't even
know a defense attorney never met one
didn't know anyone who was a criminal
didn't know anyone who might be a
criminal like he had no con he was
definitely like
a little naive with this whole thing
which I'm not even blaming him but call
what it is he definitely was and he you
know he's an immigrant from Sri Lanka he
had always believed in everything about
America
and so he thought oh the justice system
this is how it's supposed to work I've
been accused of something I think this
is totally wrong but you go into court
you argue the point they're gonna see it
because you know guilty people get found
guilty and some people don't right
especially rich ones right and that's
not really especially at that time you
know you had like the the what was it
the the mob not just the mob what was
the why am I blanking on this right now
there was Occupy Wall Street they were
like outside his trial in 2011. so it
wasn't exactly a great time for him and
obviously the media was completely
against him but he he said no I'm not
gonna inform on anything
so then they keep offering it and he's
like and and they're like you don't
understand we have like a 98 conviction
rate like you're [__] they never
wanted them but he keeps saying no and
so then he gets found guilty on all 14
counts which right before it went to the
jury his lawyer looked at him and said
we just want 14 to nothing so you know
that was quite a shock when suddenly
you know he's actually convicted he's
facing 25 years in prison
again they go to them and they say well
now you're going to go to prison but
like you know you can make this a year
or something and work for us
[__] you I'll go to prison
and you can ask Jim diorio you can ask
these other guys
that doesn't happen and that doesn't
happen in White Collar ever either but
to put it full circle with this guy you
know he did all his time he wrote that
book by hand in prison
and he has instead of you know the guys
he has not told me his net worth but I
can kind of do math talking with him the
guy the guy's worth five six billion
dollars
and he was I think he was like trading
ethereum from his jail cell in 2016. I
mean the guy's a [__] genius and he
could just go off into the sunset now
with his money and his family he's got
his total freedom at this point and
called a day after all the [__] that
happened to him but
he is making it a life calling to help
out
people who are abused by the system he
said when you go into prison it's not
like oh everybody's innocent there's a
lot of very guilty people in there but
he said the numbers probably I I think
he had an exact number based on his
estimations but it's closer to like 80
percent are fully guilty and then 90 are
maybe a little guilty or something but
maybe you're doing a lot more because
they didn't you know they got bowled
over and then 10 are not guilty and they
just got pulled over he said I could
have outspent the government six ways to
Sunday for the rest of my life every
single day that's how much money I had
and they did this to me what does that
say about everybody else so he he fights
for it and probably one of the cooler
heavier moments I had in 2022 didn't for
me personally like didn't come on the
podcast it was up in New York in
November
I was up there on on some business and
we had a meeting at Raj's office
and it was me Raj my friend Ryan Tate
who runs vet Paul another guy I think
he'd really like
uh Mark mccrane who's the original guy
who hooked me up with Raj really good
friend at this point Jim diorio was
there and then another guy Jason Flom
who is one of the co-founding board
members of the Innocence Project
and we're sitting in a room and Jason
and and Raj are going back and forth
because obviously they have a similar
passion here
and what would happen is Jason's talking
about a lot of cases he works with guys
who were put on death row and they're
innocent and DNA can prove it and all
that and then he would ask Raj about his
case to kind of relate it back in and
they're just having this back and forth
about that for a long time and maybe
like an hour in
Raj is bringing up something from his
case to answer a question where you can
tell like because you know every time
you do this you still relive it and you
could see like he's frustrated because
he has to remember this thing that
happened and like they did this and you
know this is this was his life
and he like stopped himself
he said you know
I thank God every day
that I live in this country
is the best country on planet Earth
you don't see people
going to Russia you don't see people
going to China
they come here
and you know what this is the best part
he goes
this country has been so good to me and
my family
now is he worth five six billion yes is
that good yeah I would say it's pretty
good
guy had 10 years of his life taken from
him he had his reputation which was
impeccable taken from him he has his
name plastered everywhere in a negative
light taken from him and frankly and
I'll add in my color commentary taken
from him in corruption
and he still says that and I'm telling
you Jim diorio and Ryan Tate two
veterans you're a veteran I'm watching
them across the room Ryan's almost got a
tear in his eye listening to it and Jim
who you know
gems a
that's not a dude who reacts to a lot of
things but I see him you know ex-fbi too
by the way who's the people who ran this
case on Raj
I see him like backing up
and then he he actually apologized to
Raj on behalf of the FBI too it was
really
that was something and so when I'm
sitting in there I'm like wow this all
came from like a one [__] podcast
that I did just getting these people in
the room that's kind of cool you know
when you have a conversation with a guy
like that how do you try to determine
like whether you believe them or not
right I've had people who I've spoken to
over the years who uh great question go
on to be accused and arrested of things
uh especially in the crypto industry
I've had people who uh have come on and
uh
underplayed things that were way more
heroic than they let on right like
everyone's got an angle so how do you
kind of unpack that hey guys what's
going on I hope that you're enjoying
this conversation but I wanted to
interrupt for a quick second and tell
you about a brand new conference that
I'm hosting on March 4th at the Miami
Beach Convention Center the event is
called lyceum Miami and tickets are
completely free for anyone who wants to
come I'm bringing together many of the
most popular guests from the podcast
over the last couple of years some of
the guest speakers that we've already
announced are people like Vivek
ramaswamy from strive asset management
ordelion and Mike Solana from Founders
fund Chris Williamson from the modern
wisdom podcast Cody Sanchez from
contrarian thinking and billionaire
Christian augermeyer among many others
I've got a number of amazing surprise
guests as well some that you definitely
will not expect and others that come
from walks of life that you will be
scratching your head as to how I even
got them to show up but come check out
lyceum Miami on March 4th the lyceum was
a public gym in Athens Greece where
people used to come together talk about
ideas and debate topics that were
important to society I want to meet
people in person in real life once again
after three years of a Hiatus from real
life events and so I'm hosting the event
and as I mentioned anyone from anywhere
can come to this event completely for
free all you need to do is go to
lyceumiami.com and you'll be able to
pick up a free general admission ticket
make sure you claim your ticket in order
to get in through the doors lyceum Miami
is going to be a great time so come
check it out come hang out with me many
of the popular guests from the podcast
and other like-minded individuals lyceum
Miami March 4th Miami Beach Convention
Center I hope to see you there all right
let's get back into this conversation
well to be clear I've had on a lot of
guys who are very guilty of what they
did and we're very open about that so
I I've had a couple situations I'm
trying to there was one other
where I was pretty
pretty certain that the dude hadn't
really done it I can't I'll remember it
later but for the most part like as far
as big ones it was Raj and part of that
is I
I don't have time to prepare for
podcasts I don't do it ever like I sit
there we kind of like you you know we
just turn on the cameras and mics and
start going
Raj was one podcast I think there's two
I've ever prepared for the other one a
little Raj I spent a month on that case
before he came in there I mean I knew
everything about that case and it's also
not my favorite podcast because
it was an important one to do but when I
do a second podcast with him down the
line that will be a hundred times better
because in the first one all I could
think about was I couldn't believe what
I was seeing
and I had a dude in front of me who's a
billionaire hedge fund Guy this is not a
popular guy like to say like oh I think
this guy was innocent or whatever and
all I could picture was every hole that
someone could poke into his arguments so
that podcast was very different than
other podcasts like that wherein I was
extremely active because my goal for
that one wasn't like oh let's have the
most entertaining thing today or like
let Raj talk for three hours my goal was
any [__] who can go into the comments
and say but you didn't address this
thing they wouldn't be able to do that
we have this one on the record and it's
there and I do think
knock on wood I I think we accomplished
that with that one but to answer your
question number one you don't know for
sure you can feel things in your heart
but like I think you have to listen to
your gut too with things
I would also never be able to be a
defense attorney for sure because you
know you know with with some people I
had Bill Cosby's lawyer in he ain't
gonna tell you this but I'll bet Brian
knew that Cosby did that right you know
it's tough whether you're just sitting
in a podcast seat or just a regular
person listening to a story as a
listener on the show it's tough to to
know if people are telling the truth so
all all my goal is is to put all of the
information as best as we can get it out
there and then trust my intuition and my
gut but there's never a guarantee I I
like I said though I I really
as a human I really like Raj a lot it
makes me think of uh Jose Baez I don't
know if you know who that is he's the
guy who represented uh Casey Anthony
Aaron Hernandez Harvey Weinstein a
number of other very high profile cases
isn't he doing
is he doing Sam uh I believe that he is
uh doing Tory Lanez that's the big one
yeah
um and so when you think about uh these
situations like you build a reputation
on taking on high profile clients and
defending them
um and I always think about like in the
movies but they're like you gotta tell
me did you do it or not right like
that's the way I'm going to be able to
defend you
um and so I've always thought one of the
most uh
um
entertaining slash like uh um kind of
gripping content that ever could be
captured would be something that legally
is not allowed to be captured which is
the private conversations between high
profile attorneys and their celebrity
clients
so like imagine a documentary where like
Jose Baez right if he somehow could get
the approval and had documented his
conversations with Casey Anthony with
Harvey Weinstein right with Aaron
Hernandez with Tory Lanez right it would
be a fascinating insight into the psyche
of people who are facing in many cases
uh many years in prison potential death
penalties like all these things and
did they do it did they not do it were
the details what are they thinking how
do they think about risk and reward and
reputation and you know all these
different components it is one of the
most complex uh you know scenarios that
a human can be put into and that guy
does it every day
can't imagine it that's his living yeah
yeah it's a great point you bring up and
like I said like with Brian that was a
big part of my conversation with Brian
mcmonagle the Cosby guy because
you know the I I've actually known him
throughout my whole life because he grew
up in or he was from the town I grew up
in
and I've always said this to people
especially after like the Cosby thing
happened it's like who would ever defend
that guy right but
he is probably one of the most moral
great human beings I've ever known and
not only that I've never heard someone
say a bad word about Brian mcmonagle
that doesn't have to do with I can't
believe he's repping Cosby or something
like that you know something
professional in in that way as far as
like as a person I mean people speak of
him in the highest regard and it it's
always fascinated me and I asked him
about exactly what you were just saying
probably spent like a half hour around
that topic like
how do you do it how do you leave that
at home
and he said he's an extremely humble guy
but he's like there are certain cases
that are not for me so I think he might
have used the example like if you blew
up people and you're a terrorist or
something look for a different attorney
I'm not doing that but there's still
some crazy line there where behind that
line is still some wild [__] yeah and
you know I I asked him would you let
Bill Cosby around your daughters you
have three daughters
like
how do you feel about that and he said I
don't have to answer that question
because that's not my job
my job is to put the government to the
test and he told stories about he said
look
don't get don't get it twisted when you
go in there you are going in there to
win you ain't going in there to to lose
that is the game because that's the game
you're playing against which is a whole
separate argument we could talk about
with prosecutors and things like that
but
you know are there times where perhaps
somebody got off who did it that I
represented sure
and do I maybe know it in my in my heart
if they hadn't told me
Maybe
but I'm there to do that for the guys
who didn't
and when I win those cases
there's a balance in there that sets the
world straight and my job is to make
sure the government does their job
because the Constitution says has to be
their burden of proof and again I could
never do that
I'm glad someone like him does I know
there's some scumbags who do it but
there's also a lot of good people who do
that and maybe guys like me don't do a
good enough job highlighting that so
it's nice to have him in as like a
living breathing person who can
highlight that a little bit just by
people listening to them I mean that's
really impressive stuff look I've talked
to a lot of people who uh both on the
podcast and off various law enforcement
agencies uh various
um you know kind of organizations that
look at a lot of the stuff and I will
say the one thing that uh if you talk to
somebody who's new in their career
versus somebody who's been doing it for
a while people have been doing it for a
while they're like listen this has to be
buttoned up this has to be done the
right way this has to have every single
T cross and I Dot and all these things
and a lot of times if you ask them hey
unpack that why are you so uh caught up
on like this standard of Excellence or
or getting things right you know it's
like because I actually had and I'll
name a case or they'll say my you know
my colleague had a case and somebody
came in and basically exposed that they
hadn't done their work right or hadn't
actually put the time the effort the the
care into doing it
um and so it in some ways is also a
check on power
um that I think you know he's got kind
of highlighting but it then forces law
enforcement to do the right job right
not necessarily always better job right
but it's just like do the things that
will get to a burden of proof and if you
can meet that then that's what the court
is there for now are there crazy [__]
that happened with courts all over the
place of course but it's a pretty
interesting dynamic between you know
they're meeting in a courtroom to
basically argue over ideas definitions
evidence and ultimately determine you
know kind of outcomes right and you're
determining people's freedom too that's
the crazy thing like we don't think
enough I'm not one of these people who's
like no one should go to prison and
stuff like that like I that shit's there
for a reason and you know when people do
awful things like no they should not be
a part of society I I understand that
completely and I will constantly remind
people that to not get out of control
with this stuff but
you are dealing with years or totality
of people's lives and
I do often wonder about
you know
how
what's that balance of like deterrence
and Punishment and then also accounting
for the built-in statistical percentage
of we got it wrong but we don't know we
got it wrong you know like how do you
what about those people like at the
Innocence Project who
you know they they get out of prison who
there was a guy that got out I think
Jason just finished the case a few weeks
ago a guy did 32 years
was proven that he didn't do it
it's 32 years of his life
you know it's like if you're in court
and you're not entirely sure
it's a slippery slope to say that things
can be like really really subjective
because the law is supposed to have some
sort of balance Some Like rules on the
tablet that we can follow right and this
is what happens if you don't follow it
but like you did an amazing job in the
podcast you recorded before this
bringing up the cable ask us thing I
love that I saw you right before you did
that I saw you put up his picture I'm
like oh [__] this is perfect because for
people that aren't familiar with that as
you outlined he
he's a great UFC fighter an Alzheimer
who attempted to kill a man very
publicly like wasn't wasn't trying to
hide it literally tried to gun him down
in the street yeah I think he like hit
the guy's dad in the arm or something
which you know not a great shot
apparently but
and didn't kill the guy didn't and
didn't kill him not not talented at
killing that's actually probably a bonus
but
yeah he he did that and you could just
read that and be like wow well that
guy's got to get off the street or you
could read about the fact that the dude
who he was trying to Gun Down had just
been let out on bail after being accused
of raping his his four-year-old son
hundreds of times yeah I believe I
believe it was his his son because his
daughter is like 13. check that but I
believe it was his son
and they had let the guy
out on bail and he was driving home and
came Velasquez saw red
and decided that that was not okay and
actually small world but my friend
Johnny drinks was in Dana White's office
when this news was breaking and Dana
gets the
gets the call
and like he's like upset you know like
in a weird mood obviously about it but I
think he may have even said this
publicly later but he looked right at
John because they were talking about and
they were just stunned at what had just
gone down because people are hearing
about it and he said you know we all say
if this happened we would do this
well he [__] did it
you know
am I gonna judge that like I would want
to do the same thing I don't know if I'd
have the guts to try to do what he did
but it's like breaking a law you know so
that's where it gets really weird but I
think in any system
I mean I'm not smart enough to figure it
out for sure I don't think any one
person is at all but in any system
there's always outliers with stuff and
how do you deal with those outliers and
it's tough because you know people get
one life and if you're the one caught in
the middle of it well too [__] bad
man yeah that's a bad answer but he
didn't ask to be put in that situation
no no he didn't right yeah and uh and
you're correct this is four-year-old son
and so uh
four-year-old can't fight back no and
that's that's like the worst thing you
can do besides killing a kid like
yeah I don't have kids you do right
you're like I I know from talking to a
lot of people your life changes when
that happens
I'm sure you can imagine
what you don't want to imagine but I'm
sure you could use very quick
imagination what you would want to do if
something like that happened and and I
think that's a really human thing and I
don't I no I don't think that makes him
a bad person in the slightest and I
wouldn't have like part of my whole
thing with especially locking people up
is
would I be in any way even thinking
twice if I were standing next to this
guy in line at the 7-Eleven and the
answer with a guy like that is
absolutely not well actually it's even
uh further than that which is in many
ancient societies uh even some that
aren't that far past where we live today
he would actually uh been looked down
upon if he didn't
yeah
go after the individual right right and
so the societal Norm the societal
expectation changes
it doesn't take long either no you know
in the 1920s
if you had that happen to you and you
went on the street you shot someone
I don't know if there's that many people
who are saying uh hey he shouldn't have
done that
right now part of it is society
um definitely uh advances it improves it
becomes less barbaric more comfortable
right all these things uh
but I just think that uh there's a lot
of folks who look at that situation and
they say hey it is what it is kind of
Dana White right yeah well they asked
himself what would I do in that
situation yeah but now we this that's an
interesting point you bring up too like
thinking putting a year mark on it too
like even as early as
or late I should say is the 1920s that's
not that long ago especially in the
context of time it's like
you know the internet was still a
far-off thing TV was still not a thing
this mass communication wasn't there
we hadn't fought World War II yet you
know there wasn't the life expectancy I
don't know what the exact life
expectancy was but I would imagine you
know it certainly wasn't 77. and I think
one of the patterns over time is that we
take life and the value of life
so much more seriously as like a human
culture as time progresses
and yet
there's things that then we don't take
seriously about it when we're thinking
about oh yeah they just locked that guy
up for 100 years okay go about my day or
we take it so seriously that we inject
like safety into everything
and you can suddenly make an argument
that you know what it's not safe for us
to cross the street anymore
it's like who do I gotta [__] for some
Middle Ground here I think we should
absolutely take life seriously but let's
do it on all levels and let's also allow
people to have
you know make decisions and so guess
what sometimes people make bad decisions
and the worst thing happens and that
sucks and I'm not
unepathetic to that but statistically
speaking
it happens yeah you know we talked about
someone like Raj who kind of you get
through it and your opinion is hey he
you know didn't kind of do the things
that they accuse him of doing uh and
then you said that you've had people on
who uh definitely did what they were
accused of doing
um I'm wondering uh the bit another big
one that I remember uh you should check
this guy Matthew Cox yes who did uh I
think the FBI uh had him as one of the
most wanted people uh on their list is
the g-fote you know about that explain
this it's the greatest fraud of all time
yes explain it so he you've seen the
movie Catch Me If You Can yes which now
supposedly Frank Abagnale uh made up the
whole story
apparently he was a fraud of a fraud so
he didn't actually do these things and
there's very good evidence to point that
out which I immediately took a picture I
could give it to you too if you want to
stick it on the screen but when I found
out that news I sent Matt like where I
do this thing where I'll send those
three red lights I'll send three at a
time really big like 47 times so
people's phones blow up and then I sent
him a picture of Michael Jordan with his
face on it with Matt's face on it and I
wrote g-fote you're officially the
greatest fraud of all time but yeah you
started to say right he
he was and it didn't take long I mean
the guy never committed a crime until he
was 30 years old and it only took five
six years before he was locked up but
the dude was in modern history like the
biggest con man the FBI dealt with I
mean he was
he was wild and and he is a
like I I like Matt I call him a friend I
texted Matt a lot he's been on a couple
times he's really tight with Danny Jones
who's podcast with him were [__]
amazing and he has them on all the time
it's like
you know it's kind of funny sometimes
when I get along with them but I look at
Matt as like almost like a science
experiment a little bit because he's so
it's like he's now so hyper aware of the
[__] he did
was when he did it
no awareness you're just doing it [__]
you you know he he's a he's a natural
narcissist everything's about him that
has to do a lot with his childhood and
stuff like that but you know it made him
like the first crime that he ever
committed
technically I don't know
it was a crime but I don't even know if
it was so small I don't know if they
trusted in court I think it was 2002
with the mortgage fraud I think it was
like 2 000 but yeah yeah and and he
didn't uh uh he didn't go to jail or
anything they just like probation and
then he got fired as a mortgage broker
I'm talking even before then okay the
very first time anything happened he was
late on his bills like he had you know
car bills he had a young son which was
an accident and a wife who it's
hilarious when he talks about his first
wife because they like talk all the time
today but they like rib each other it's
very funny but
he couldn't close a mortgage
and he finally closes one and so he goes
back to his manager's office he hands
all the documents over and this is you
know this is 2000. this is back in the
wild wild west where anything passed but
she starts going through the files and
he's just standing there and she goes um
and she's putting everything like it's a
yes like over here on the side okay
okay
puts that paper off to the side one off
to the right side keeps going
everything's good and at the end he's
like oh we only got one over there this
is a full stack we must be good and she
looks up and she goes unfortunately we
can't do it he's like what the [__] like
what do you mean we can't do this and
she says well
I think it was he wrote his income is 62
000 it needs to be at least 69. and
Matt's like oh my God
I can't close a deal they're gonna take
my car like all this [__] and she goes
don't worry about it
pulls the desk out takes out white out
whites out the two makes it a nine she
goes all better and gives it to him and
he looks at her like she just invented
fire and he's just like
what you can just don't worry about it
it's like
oh I'm gonna do that again and he just
started that's where it started and then
a lot there you know skipping everything
it runs into you know he's the greatest
Identity Thief to ever live you know I
got him in my dad's house and my dad's
like how easily could you take this he
goes Dave I could have taken the whole
[__] neighborhood in the last 10
minutes this is not hard you know like
the things he would do you really have
to listen to him tell the stories
because I won't do it any justice he's
so another guy you should have in he's
so entertaining but he like he's been in
twice
and like I said I do it just we go with
the flow and I didn't plan this but it
worked perfectly the first time we
covered his life of crime all the way up
to when he went on to the run from the
FBI because it was three and a half
hours in I'm like we gonna We Gotta stop
right second time I'm thinking okay now
we'll finish the story no we covered
three and a half hours his whole life on
the run and cut off right when he got
arrested and now the third time I'm
gonna bring him in we're gonna cover
prison and hopefully get through it but
the guy
is so entertaining like the way he tells
a story but as he'll say guilty as Sin
in fact for all the things they charged
him with and it was a lot
like they probably missed some things
like he's so open about it and we've had
plenty of guys like that Tim McBride's
another one
and his wasn't like you know he was just
like a huge pot Smuggler no guns no
nothing like perfectly safe like the D.A
liked him you know they didn't go too
hard on him but you know guys like that
were guilty of what they did and and
I've had plenty of where it's like
there's not really a question here the
only I remembered the other one the only
other one I had where
he actually was guilty but the law was
[__] was my friend Nick Castellucci
came on and he was one of the original
Xbox underground hackers
and so
I was explained his case incorrectly
before he came in so I really kind of
[__] up but he was great and like
walked it walked me through it like six
times because I kept I kept thinking in
my head I'm like there's no way I'm
hearing this right because I heard this
guy stole money and that's not what I'm
hearing but essentially there was a
really broad law I forget what it's
called that lets you it gives the
government the leeway to charge almost
anyone
selling some sort of second party
service with a felony as an example
what Nick did to put it very simply
there's things called FIFA coins that
you earn playing the game FIFA and when
you take those coins
you get them for like you finish playing
a game against the computer they give
you coins and they're not worth any
money but you can like get a messy
Jersey or something in the game
so it's not like they don't there's
never a point where FIFA sells those
coins for a dollar value they are worth
nothing but people go online and on the
second market for people who are like
trying to get clout in FIFA they sell
them so Nick and Xbox underground
figured out they broke the terms of
service absolutely so like of course
FIFA had every right to kick them out of
the game forever like it was not ethical
but they broke the terms of service and
and figured out how to earn points like
immediately so they were printing
millions of coins the coin Market I
think it was something like they were
selling a million coins for 65 was the
market rate these guys got involved
suddenly it became eight dollars and
they were making seven figures on the
secondary Market selling it around the
world to people who just like playing
FIFA
the government goes in and paints this
whole fraud case out of it
and by the letter of this law and I've
talked to lawyers on this they can do it
like they can convict you it like
according to the law he broke it but for
people at home wondering like well how
easy is this to break as an example
you ever get those texts from the guys
who are selling you the idea of growing
your Instagram following of course every
single one of them is breaking the same
exact law
that is the exact same thing if you are
taking something from the terms of
service of some private entity and using
some sort of
hacking mechanism to break that and then
monetizing that and I'm explaining
lawyers are going to yell at me for not
explaining this all the way but like
that's what he was charged with and so
what's really sad about his case is
there were four of them charged and it
was a slam dunk case right and so the
agents wouldn't allow them to talk to
each other and they told all the guys
that everyone you know pleaded guilty
and whatever
turns out one of them they didn't offer
that to and he had to go to trial
and he got found guilty and he killed
himself
wow and so Nick who is like the nicest
he did this was when he was 19 years old
he didn't know like what was going on
nicest dude ever you know we didn't
really talk about uh on the podcast
because he he
asked not to and so I didn't get to ask
a lot of questions but that's fine but
that's something he now
lives with forever and yet you know he
handles this so professionally and so
well and like his career's worked out
because he's a brilliant
coder and hacker so he's okay but
you know you think about stuff like that
and you're like there's you know there's
some real Downstream consequences to
these things so when people do things
where maybe the law actually is [__]
up maybe you should think about that
maybe you should think about what that
means you know like in Australia I had
Australian lawyers hit me up like oh
dude we study some of your Tech laws or
however they I don't know how they say
it but we study some of your laws here
and how [__] crazy they are I'm like
that's rich Australia's telling us we're
crazy like something's you know we're a
little backwards here based on the last
couple years but that's I think you can
do that with any country you know
there's some some sort of hole in the
system so I happen to walk into one
there where the guy was in the hole but
all the other ones Louisa he was an
original Cocaine Cowboy guilty as Sin
did 13. uh
who also buy it in I always find that
the people who are guilty they just say
it yes they just talk about like they're
just like look yeah I did it you got me
cool I did my time thank you I'll move
on with my life that's it right they're
actually like pretty honest about uh and
and again maybe they're exaggerating
maybe they're leaving things out
whatever but like they're not usually
trying to uh downplay or hide it in some
ways uh they're almost proud of it
some of them right like there's like a
pride to it yeah and it's easier I think
once they've left that life behind to
talk about it with Nostalgia to some
degree
I think it depends on what it is but
like a guy like Tim McBride bless you
who was
you know moving weed
he never did it again he left the game
behind and this is back in the you know
he was part of chokolusky Island down in
Florida and they basically like this is
when cocaine was huge and so the Cubans
they didn't even
they didn't know how to bring it in
through the Everglades like the weed
they were worried about the Coke and all
that so they just had these regular
Floridians living down in this little
place in the southern Everglades on the
west coast of Florida running all the
weed like they were like the biggest
ones one of the biggest ones ever in
this country and you know once he was
done he was like The Godfather when he
was like 25 doing that gets caught when
he's 29 this is late 80s
never did it again left the game but he
does speak about it with some Nostalgia
because to this day like he's friends
with I think it was like the Secretary
of Homeland Security for Florida
who calls him Legend right and he's like
that was the biggest mistake we ever the
guy who ran the whole case against him
who there were every agency was on it
but I think this guy was Secret Service
they're really good friends today
because he's like I can't believe we
wasted all our money on this like it was
weed you guys had no guns like it's way
worse now because now the people who do
it it's all the cartels it's a mess but
you know it was breaking the law and he
knows that so he never did it again and
so he can wax poetic you know and not
necessarily feel bad about it neither do
I on that one but you know he's still
like very upfront like yeah I went to
prison I broke federal law that's kind
of what it is yeah probably shouldn't
have done that
technically yes whereas Matt Cox it's
like I should have never like he knows
he should have never done that yeah what
um what makes a good conversation like
that you enjoy forget like the audience
forget numbers on YouTube or uh podcast
downloads like what makes a good
conversation for you well I got to be
interested in it
sometimes if I'm just having you know we
I still do episodes and I always will
and hopefully I'll do like even more
moving forward but I have episodes where
we're just talking right it's not like
some feature story
or something and those are fun because
if they're Lively if you're trying to
make sense of this big [__] confusion
world we have these days and all the
goddamn opinions out there which I
always tell people please for the love
of God don't take my opinion seriously
like I'm just like you trying to figure
it out you know I I think when you go
about it that way and the other person
is kind of like your dance partner in
that
the only difference between that and a
regular conversation having whiskey at
the bar is the fact that we have cameras
up and we're in a studio and you forget
that like maybe the real best way to
answer that question is
the thing that makes a great
conversation is when you forget the
cameras are there within five minutes
and I can honestly say you know that has
been
I can't remember the last time because
you know I produce everything myself
still unfortunately and all that but I
can't remember the last time I didn't
forget about the cameras five minutes in
in the podcast and I think that's a real
Testament to the people who have come
through there obviously that means we're
hitting on people who
of course know how to talk and
communicate but are bringing a lot to
the table if it's a crazy story enough
said right if I brought in Someone Like
You
there's a lot there like I don't really
have to do anything I just gotta keep
you [__] moving but you know other
ones where there's more back and forth
or whatever you obviously have people
who are great conversationalists
themselves and that just
it's a good feeling I mean like why do
you why do you
you were obviously already an extremely
successful guy worked and earned your
way and everything
why did you get into content when you
didn't have to at all that's a cheat
code I got to talk to anyone I want
there you go and why do you like talking
to anyone you want excellent there you
go yeah it is uh it's a single easiest
way to get people uh uh to have a
conversation with me is by the way I'll
do something in return for you I'll
blast it out to this big audience and
you can get all the value you can talk
about whatever you want you gotta uh you
know something you're working on you got
a book coming out whatever like whatever
you need however I can make you
successful I'll do it hey guys I hope
that you're enjoying this conversation
as you probably realize we don't run any
ads on this show that's right all the
other podcasts all the other YouTube
shows that you watch they have
advertisers we don't have any direct
relationships with advertisers and we
simply create this because we enjoy
doing it now that we do that though we
have a team and if you'd like to support
us one way you can do that is to go
subscribe to the pomp letter it's a
daily letter that I write to about 235
000 people about my personal opinion on
financial markets business technology
and Bitcoin just go to pompletter.com
and you can sign up there I'd love to
have you join us and it's a great easy
way to support the work that the team
and I are doing on a daily basis alright
let's get back into this conversation
talk to me what I like about you is
and for people listening out there I'll
say this
you and I have mutual friends my older
friends at College were your younger
friends when you were there and so
back in 2018
unrelated this other kid Cole canelli
shout out Cole
he had connected with you
and I'd call this my boy and I was
talking with him all the time like wait
you met with pop I'm like I know people
who know pomp I never [__] met this
guy and so my little idiot self was like
I'd love to go I love sitting with
people so I'm like I love to go sit with
pong so when when my guys got in touch
with you to ask that because I asked
them you were like [__] yeah and I
didn't I didn't think about this at all
right I'm still working as a banker at
the time you're like literally the guy
trying to end the banks here never
entered my lexicon but I go in to meet
you
I was
it was the end of December 2018 in New
York and Bitcoins at three thousand
dollars do you remember what you did in
that meeting no
I would tell this story too because you
won't talk about conviction let's do a
little great PR for you right now in the
we met for you gave me an hour more than
an hour of your time on a Monday I was
some [__] 24 year old in a suit who
works at a bank I'm the last person that
you should be given any time to and you
never like I my idiot self realized that
later but would have never thought that
way like it was just great for me to
learn from someone who was out there
killing it and doing really cool [__]
and
you know I was so impressed with that
and and I had nothing to offer you but
you made a point at keeping in touch
with me and everything so I just thought
that was like the coolest thing and I
really appreciated it but in the middle
of that meeting we were I was just
asking you all kinds of questions about
markets and Technology with markets and
this and that and at some point like the
price of Bitcoin came up
because I asked it and it was the only
time you whipped out your phone the
entire meeting and like real fast you
like reach down pull it out flip it over
you're like okay let's see Bitcoin
uh 33 87 it's never going to go lower
than that I would take every dollar I
have and put it in Bitcoin right now
bitcoin's having a tough time right now
but it's a lot higher than that and I
want people to go look at a chart of
Monday December 17 2018
of Bitcoin and you're gonna see a bottom
tick the 15th through the 17th right
there
this guy then gets in the elevator
afterwards I go to take a piss when
we're done say goodbye
I go the elevator pump gets in the
elevator and rides it down with me I'm
like where are you going guy went home
and bought Bitcoin he didn't just tell
me to go buy Bitcoin he went and did it
him his damn self and he called the
bottom of the market so that was that
was I tell some people that story I
don't know if I told that ever like
publicly but that was I still think even
when bitcoin's like struggling stuff I
still think about that a lot because
you know I have been
I think a lot of the criticism that
you've been getting since this FDX thing
which I would love to talk with you
about has been very very unfair and it's
not just you you know there's there's
other people getting it too but it feels
like an attack on the system and and
people you know when things go bad
they're always looking for people they
can blame and I see some of the other
people in the Bitcoin Community who are
a little bit over Maxi I guess or
whatever who come at you and I think
that's just like kind of gross but you
know
I had asked you in that meeting and I'm
going to mess up exactly how you said it
because you said it really profoundly
but I'm gonna get the point across I'd
ask you in that meeting something to the
effect of
you know pop what
if you're wrong about this stuff now I'm
sitting there as a Believer like I own
this [__] I still have never sold a dime
of any crypto I've ever bought you know
some of it that I'm like I don't know
about that but other stuff I'm like okay
I see it but I asked you that and you
were real matter of fact you're like
look
I believe that you have to go search for
Great evidence on things that are you
know towards Innovation or something to
that effect and when you have great
evidence if you believe it can stand up
against the counter evidence in a good
way you should put your heart and your
mind behind it and you should be willing
to say that [__] publicly and say it to
anyone who would listen and if you're
wrong you need to figure out afterwards
why you're wrong and that's how life
goes and then you got to move to the
next thing and build better evidence but
it wasn't like oh I'm just going to go
to something and see if I'm right it was
like look this is I've made this my life
this you know obviously you were part of
what's what's yusco's company called
Morgan Creek right so you've been a part
of Morgan Creek at that point for a
while you've done Full Tilt I guess like
two three years earlier you worked your
way up through Silicon Valley like it's
not like you were hopping on this on a
Monday and you and I are talking on
Tuesday this is a very different thing
and and you know I knew like anyone
would know that the criticism that comes
with putting yourself in the middle of
those bullets to say nothing of like
building your following on Twitter which
I'm not jealous that you did that like I
think Twitter's the weirdest place to
build a following it's very hard but
like you know to put yourself out there
like that requires a lot of bravery and
how many tweets do you have now like a
hundred thousand two hundred thousand uh
number of tweets yeah probably sixty
seventy thousand whatever same [__] you
know
I could go find 200 Tweets in there that
are probably horrible that you had like
I I was watching you before this when we
were in your office and you were talking
with me about something you flipped up
Twitter and I watched how fast you did
stuff that you were not thinking about
which is perfectly fine but I'm thinking
like what if one of those likes he just
gave that there's no way he read that
tweet says like you know Sam bankman's a
great guy like someone can go run that
screenshot three years from now yeah and
people be like [__] this guy or whatever
and so you know seeing you deal with the
things that have come your way
in light of this FTX thing that we're
going to talk about like
I found a lot of it to be pretty gross I
think if there's one thing though that
is kind of one of those like criticism
compliments it's that you are interested
in a lot of [__] and you're also really
smart so you want to do a lot of
different things and from the outside
you probably try to do too much yeah of
course right I get one life though
that's true but like I want to do a lot
too I know a lot of other people want to
do a lot we're not doing as much as you
are maybe we could be doing more
you know I think when you're talking
about [__] where it's like people are
investing their money and you're not
telling them to do it on a lot of this
stuff that was another misconception
people had
they'll find a way to paint you with
that so I I like your decision to remove
the advertisers and stuff and and kind
of get past that because I do think it
was pretty much
a perfect storm to come at you with all
this but I gotta I gotta ask after all
that like what
not that you saw it coming or anything I
don't think anyone did but when you
first get the whiff of of that FTX news
when it was first like oh maybe
something's wrong here
what's going through your mind nothing
nothing
you have to remember uh
across business
um across a lot of this stuff
um
most of the people that you see yelling
and screaming they're not professionals
right and so like
the amount of money that was lost in
some of these companies some of them I
was investor and some of them I wasn't
uh
people would like
jump off Bridges literally right in
terms of uh
this stuff and
by the way also you have to think not
just about the aggregate dollar amounts
lost but the percentage of money that
some people lost
right some people had
five dollars but that five dollars meant
a hell of a lot to them yes or 500 or 5
000 or 50 000 right
um and so it's not to say that any one
person feels more or less pain or
anything like that but it's
The Professional
knows that they're taking risk the
professional knows that it could not
work
and so um
you know if you think of value lost in
all of this uh yeah we're up there for
sure in terms of uh probably taking some
of the biggest L's in all of it but also
we took a lot of W's along the way
and
you don't hear me complaining about it
right and it's because
um
you can't change the past you can only
go forward and it's also a thing of like
even though many people would look at
like the quote-unquote risk management
that take me personally me as an
individual
that I overlay on my life they'd be like
that's crazy
risk management just means um take the
simple example of uh how much of my net
worth I put in Bitcoin okay there's a
lot of people who would say oh why would
you ever put more than five percent
right right and usually when I would ask
people I'd say put two to three percent
right yeah and the part that's hilarious
to me about the entire situation is
um
probably the most conservative person or
one of the most conservative people
um
most of the people I know in the Bitcoin
Community say go put all of your money
in Bitcoin why do you have any dollars
right I think the speech you were giving
me this is back in 2018 but I think you
were saying you were running around the
companies saying
get off zero yeah
one person it wasn't like crazy
literally I'm the I am For Better or
Worse the person who started saying get
off zero yeah and get to one percent
right
um and so like not really that risky
yeah uh on top of that
um
for every person who is you know said
all the stuff about these advertisers
it's like listen
if regulators and other people were all
uh deceived tricked whatever
I'm not gonna no one person is gonna
like figure it out right
and then on top of that uh
nobody ever talks about uh all of the
advertisers that uh did custody
Solutions or had self-custody or private
Key Management right yeah of course it's
only to talk about the losers well not
even just the losers it's the ones that
fit their narrative yeah exactly right
exactly and so like you know look I I uh
uh the problem for a lot of the
individuals who are yelling and
screaming is I've been doing this longer
than them many of them
and I've actually been on the inside I'm
not an idiot on the internet who comes
from the traditional Financial world and
it's like oh I don't understand Bitcoin
right right right I know all the players
I know who is ethical and who's not I
know which companies are completely full
of [__] and run and using the name
Bitcoin to actually mislead Their
audience
and I know who the good players are
and I've just held my tongue
and at some point maybe I won't I
haven't decided yet how how I would you
know kind of pers move forward but what
I can say is that there's a lot of
people who are yelling and screaming and
beating their chest
and that long list of people doing that
are the exact people
that they're all hiding something
they're trying to distract from the
things that they're doing and what I
always
you know there's a there's something I
learned in my life over the years that
the more somebody yells about something
the more likely it is that they're
actually trying to hide something and
you see this with like uh politicians
you know that they'll be uh uh pushing
all this like anti-gay legislation and
then it turns out that they have like a
uh you know it's a man who's a male
lover or something right like like
there's always like something right and
so the second that I see someone
beating their chest talking about how
they're virtuous
or they're ethical or they're honest
I immediately just read Flags go up
right alarms go off and what's crazy to
me is that
um
regardless of how this nonsense Bitcoin
just doesn't care
right like block after block after block
Bitcoin doesn't even know Twitter exists
right it just continues to produce
blocks of transactions and most
bitcoiners aren't on Twitter
that's not really no
there are probably more people who hold
Bitcoin at this point than monthly
active users of Twitter
on the entire platform
right what's the market cap at this
moment like fine it's it's back above 20
so like 500 the total market cap of
Bitcoin right now is 400 billion right
almost exactly okay and it's estimated
that uh there's anywhere between 150 and
250 million people who hold Bitcoin and
any amount of Bitcoin right okay
what is Twitter's monthly active user
number well probably 200 million 250
maybe 300 million like it's not a
billion here's a better question than
how many people
own Bitcoin and actively recognize the
fact that they own Bitcoin and pay any
attention to it that might be that's
because of course that makes a ton of
sense like we know Toyota doesn't have
anywhere near those numbers but as far
as like people who even if they don't
own a [__] ton like I'm I'm pretty poor
like I don't want to [__] them but it's
my money right so I think most people
who have Bitcoin know they own Bitcoin
and they pay attention
okay right now is it let's say there's
200 million people who own Bitcoin maybe
98 of them
you know know it and two percent don't
or something but like most people who
hold Bitcoin know they have Bitcoin yeah
and it's because there's High friction
to getting it still can you can you
explain that
as far as like are you just saying like
it's you have to go through a process to
get it you have to be able to store on
it I don't pick it up on the ground it's
not like oh I found five dollars I put
in my pocket I forgot I had it right
right like you you have to have done
something to get it usually
um in terms of signed up gone through
kyc process uh gone and bought something
talked to a financial like there's
there's multiple ways you could get it
bought a minor to actually mine Bitcoin
you had to go through some kind of
friction and so it's like a conscious
opt-in decision to get it
um now you may forget where it is you
may forget how much you have uh you know
whatever
but you know that you got some Bitcoin
right for the most part and people who
may even know I had Bitcoin but I think
I lost it they still know I had Bitcoin
right I do know that
um those stories give me Aja yeah and so
I think the the biggest lesson frankly
over the last year is like
don't have Heroes right and uh what I
think that we are watching is like
that's true outside of the Bitcoin
ecosystem it's also true inside of the
Bitcoin ecosystem right and like that's
just a great thing in life is like don't
put people on a pedestal don't have
these Heroes
um
there's also a lot of hypocrisy a lot of
hypocrisy and my approach to this stuff
usually is just like look I just kind of
take the high road there's people who
literally spent there's literal accounts
that have been dedicated to just
attacking me relentlessly over and over
and over some of them are straight up
spam accounts obviously right oh they I
mean we haven't even gotten into like
the whole uh there's definitely entire
bot networks that are created I probably
blocked hundreds if not thousands of
accounts that were created in November
2022 and all they did was tweet at me
did you see the one this one was kind of
funny
the there was like five Pakistani dudes
who were doing the I started cracking up
they were doing the
block five rocket ship
what else all right well at least that
one's real yeah because you see these
accounts and it looks like it says
they're created in November 2022 or
whatever and it's just like look at a
pump liano is the devil or it just you
know people should be able to know that
but they don't sometimes well and also
you have to remember that uh you'll
never be attacked by someone who's doing
more than you
probably true right yeah never
unless it's like you're like Sam bankman
or something then you might get attacked
by people doing more did anyone else
who's attacking him build a 40 billion
dollar company I'm not so sure he did
so that it begs the question right yeah
but like you start to look at it and
you're like who is attacking him now
again I don't want to defend him
whatsoever or I don't think anything
that he is alleged of doing is good
should have been done all this stuff how
long have you known him by the way I
didn't I don't know him super well I
interviewed him once I think we talked
one other time
that's pretty much it
um okay but if you look at you know look
he really kind of only came on the scene
in 20 19 20 20 ish time right
um so he hasn't even been around really
for that long two three years right yep
um
but yeah I just think that a lot of
times when you see people attacking
others on the internet
almost never is the attacker doing more
than the attackie and that's true forget
like all the Bitcoin crypto stuff right
like that's just like in general
politics like all this stuff and so
um I think it surprises us when somebody
does do it right like if Elon Musk
punches down on someone I think that's
why people are so offended yeah right
because they're like wait a minute dude
you're like one of the richest people in
the world like why like like this is
beneath you yeah right that's also why
we see politicians like if a politician
ever goes after like a private citizen
like dude this is like weird this is
like beneath you like as a society we're
thrown off right
um but man are we very really acceptable
of the opposite we are that's what the
you know that's there's a lot of
positives and negatives with everything
obviously but that is to be the total
Captain Obvious point the one of the
huge downsides of the internet and the
instant connectivity is the ability of
of not proper criticism that's always
good but you what you're talking about
which is where you know people create
fake people and do it and and they they
create I mean look at
I think the whole xrp movement happened
because Bots were created you know I
talked to the guy who took that down
he'll never come on the podcast but it's
like
that involves like moving financial
markets so where is this 20 years 20
years Skip Bayless has attacked LeBron
James
for 20 years LeBron's never responded
LeBron's never responded now I won't I
won't say who it is but I know someone
very close to LeBron who has literally
wrestled his phone out of his hand yeah
to get him from responding so don't
think that he's immune he doesn't read
it he isn't upset pissed frustrated all
those things he's a human
for 20 years that's a good friend
he just said hey man taking the phone
just get to practice man yeah go win
championships the fact is he that
definitely means he usually does
completely ignore him which is very
impressive because I think
you know I don't like criticizing people
unless you know it's like Sam bankman or
something obvious where it's like they
did a lot of [__] wrong but
Skip Bayless is everything that is wrong
with media like if you want to point it
out and he's not even in politics like
which is really crazy to think about but
I don't know
that dude has monetized
[__] like he's monetized [__]
hate of specific people or [__] love
I mean we all remember the Tebow
movement and [__] like that nothing
against him but like obviously wasn't a
great NFL quarterback at all
Skip Bayless thought he was Jesus Christ
literally
in a football uniform and it's like you
know people like that if they the point
you're making here that's interesting is
like
they've always existed in the mainstream
narrative before we had all this stuff
where the critics Rose to the top right
so what makes you think that once you
give people a keyboard and an account
they're not gonna they're not gonna
spread that as much as they can because
they just that person that skip just
represents a lot of other people who
would be the same way most of the people
who are yelling and screaming at
strangers on the internet are just
unhappy people with themselves yes right
they're deeply and happy and actually if
you can take the approach as somebody
who's usually on the other end of it and
be uh compassionate yeah and can be
empathetic and could say man how bad of
a day do you have to be going through
yeah to say that
I've had death threats I've had people
say all kinds of crazy insane things and
I always think like the things that
people say if I took what they said
and I've made them put it on a T-shirt
and walk around for a day they'd be
embarrassed oh yeah right
but guess what
they probably going through some [__]
most likely and I I do I share your
sentiment in dealing with a lot of it I
mean I have fun with most of it like I
consider it engagement it's it's huge
help so you know I'll [__] with them but
you know I've also never had to deal
with
like the only thing I've ever done is
make some content it's only so much that
you know you get people who disagree
with opinions but like so what
when you're dealing with movements like
you have I mean that's that's where
you've been you've been on the Forefront
of like
crypto or Bitcoin and things that affect
people's future Viewpoint of like the
world and how it impacts geopolitics and
[__] that's a whole nother realm and the
criticism that you open yourself up to
there in my opinion is on a whole like I
can't
can't relate to that I I don't know what
that is I'm glad I don't know what that
is but I think I I do think you've
really dealt with the stuff that's been
coming your way well by taking the high
road and it's nice to hear you
seem to like sitting across me right now
you seem to really I read it all back to
Heart yeah that's what people don't
understand most people just shut off
their phone I read every single comment
every single name said to me I loved it
you loved it because it just fired me up
I literally I'll never forget I was
sitting on the couch one day and playing
a uh walking into the room shoes what
are you doing
and I was like I'm reading everything
this is like one of the bad days and
she's like stop doing that yeah and I
was like I want to remember every single
thing these people are saying I read
every single comment and I and and by
the way like you're not supposed to do
that right like rule number one on the
internet don't read the comments but I
read everything yeah and
my take away from it was I learned a lot
but I learned a lot
people want someone to yell at and what
you were saying one of the conclusions I
came to is like when you get Praise on
the way up
you gotta basically just be a man and
eat the [__] hate on the chin on the
way down 100 sure right but you also
have to find a balance between uh
these people are using you
as a cheap option for engagement for
themselves yeah right and so
if you can just remember
who you are and what you do whatever
somebody said it to me
um I'll say who it is uh but he said pop
while they're yelling at you you gave a
presentation to a central bank about
Bitcoin yeah
yeah
right so like
again super fortunate of the
opportunities to do stuff like that but
like how disjointed
right of reality from all this stuff
well because people take themselves too
seriously and they take every single
little thing too seriously and then when
you add their money into it all bets are
off but you know the other thing about
you is like you like to just like have
fun
you know you're like almost in like a
fun corny way too like always just
trying like I always see you with a
smile your content kind of comes across
that way too and God knows you're on
Twitter all the [__] time typing [__]
out I know some of it's got to be boring
but still you know like there's a lot of
it where you know you're a cheerleader
with stuff that's going on and that's an
easy target for these cynics to go after
like oh pump you're not putting the
Bitcoin price on there on the way down
and [__] and I ain't gonna lie on the
way up I was thinking like uh
might eat some of this on the way down
but you know like that's exactly that's
genuinely you so I'm all right with that
but you know also people gotta do what
they're gonna do the way I do something
is totally different from you know the
way other people do it so I really try
not to judge that too much but you know
for all the people who are trying even
before the FTX thing who were like
trying to Levy
criticism against you for like
sleuthing your activity online like
people would be like oh he got rid of
the laser eyes or like oh my God he
hasn't tweeted about Bitcoin since three
days laser eyes was my favorite thing I
literally took the laser eyes off like
three months before anyone said anything
right and literally the first one they
tweeted me I almost responded it was
like glad to see all are paying
attention
but like do you think because when you
go to put [__] like that on like that's
the kind of stuff even if I were
involved with this like I just wouldn't
do because I I try to keep like a as
much as I can like just level kind of
the same [__] give my opinions whatever
call it a day but you know when you
start to get caught up in in the fact
that yeah people are having fun with
things there's little movements that
happen like when you go to put laser
eyes on your profile for the first time
like is there the thought like uh maybe
it's gonna be awkward if I ever have to
take these off no [__] no no you just
[__] do it who cares
who cares if I take them off if you're
so they shouldn't hurt I agree that I
put laser eyes on or took them off or
whatever then you need a new hobby like
you're a loser for caring about what
other people on the internet do with
other profile pictures or their bios or
whatever like I said to somebody who is
very well known in the space he DM me uh
privately and he was like Hey Hey man uh
did you sell your Bitcoin
it's like what she's like taking down
your laser eyes I said bro you're a
grown ass man this dude's worth billions
of dollars I was like you're [__] on
the internet right now worried about
what people are doing with their profile
pictures I was like dude go hang out
your family right like go like what are
you talking about uh
and we had a good laugh about it like he
was whatever but like
I think that also uh
the risk is you can't turn Bitcoin into
a religion and there's some people who
are trying to do that I think it's a
real dangerous thing and I think and and
in all fairness and honesty like I think
sometimes it's people who have been
associated with you or that may even be
friends of yours and whatever and I see
some of this stuff and it gets cringe
it's one thing when you're kind of
joking about it like my friend Matt
kemenosh we always have fun with that
he's like a long-term Bitcoin guy knows
so much [__] like has we joke like the
religious experience I call them Bitcoin
Jesus but like
he pulls it back to Earth and he's like
yeah look this is why I believe in it
like I speak once it crossed into uh oh
[__] these people actually want this to
be a religion I was out like in terms of
like the public uh uh coalescing of uh
that message
that's not why that's not why I ever
came here that's not why I am here and
that's frankly not why I'll be here
years and years and years from now
um so how do you view yourself right now
like you wouldn't it seems to me and I
think that's probably a good thing but
you wouldn't call yourself like a
Bitcoin Maxi I I don't even know like
that term now has been so co-opted and
like there are people use it as a
negative as a positive whatever like I
think Bitcoin is the most important idea
of Our Generation and if it ends up
being successful on a global scale as
bitcoiners and myself believe it will be
it will probably have the root
solution the first principle solution to
so many problems in society because it
ultimately brings uncorrupted money to
the world like it it is so undervalued
as an idea
some of it's because people don't
understand it some of it's because that
like scares the [__] out of people some
of us because they're like oh there's no
way in my lifetime like that would be
built whatever
but like that's what I'm interested in
like basically all the like toxicity all
the [__] it's just like peer pressure
[__] yes that's exactly what it is like
yo y'all don't know me I've never been
peer pressured to do [__] I don't give a
[__] right and
if you need that to be happy more power
to you like like be happy and so I have
friends who uh very very good friends
who like would even be considered
leaders in that group
but they are not the type of people who
go and attack people right they're not
the type of people who go and put people
down there's not zero-sum game to them
it's not I put you down so I feel better
about myself what they look at is I'm
really convicted in this idea how can I
help you learn how can I bring you in
here well that's the attitude people
that's the positive attitude of course
people want but you haven't and it's
nice to hear you lay it out Simply like
that but you know to be clear what I'm
hearing
is from my end over here it's like
I don't hear any difference in your
belief than what I heard in 2018 or what
I've been you know when I talk with you
on the phone or you know just follow
your your Twitter or the things you're
saying like it seems to me like you're
still
in this low moment so to speak of crypto
you're still every bit as passionate
about the Innovation forget price forget
all that I'm more convicted today than
I've ever been
because when we talked in 2018
there's now four years of continued
progress growth adoption and it's been
de-risked by four years of progress it
was riskier in 2018 than it is now and
that's reflected in the price
right yes that makes sense and so it's
less risky today than it was in 2018 in
my opinion I'm also one of the things I
tweeted this back in November and I
don't think people really understood it
I said I think I may be one of the only
people to publicly interview Michael
Saylor
people dokwon SPF safedine CZ and I said
and many others including the people
from Ripple and all these other places
right you're Garling you were you had an
early Garling house one that was really
good and here's the thing is
many people who have this strong opinion
about Bitcoin
they haven't done the work to talk to
the other people
right they haven't actually gone and had
it there is no show me the work that you
did yes you can look at mine I talked to
1200 people
and you also get you also get hit for
having an open mind to other Innovations
say in the space and by the way it
doesn't mean you're going to be right
about it as we've seen with some of the
things that have blown up that in my
opinion I don't think you can look at
any period in say modern history of
Technology where smart people didn't
like go towards things that didn't hit
right some of the people all your
investments in Full Tilt some of those
didn't work right well some of the
people on that list I I'm the one who
taught them about Bitcoin I'm the one
who orange killed them hmm interesting
some of them some of them I learned from
yeah but that's how the world works
right is there's people who came before
us
like in terms of I think it was like my
class of people who came into Bitcoin
that I learned an immense amount from I
had to study them I had to pick up and
read the books listen to the podcast
read the articles call them interview
them ask them quite like all of that
stuff I had I started at zero I knew
nothing and I built a base of Knowledge
from all of the people who came before
me
and then as time progressed new people
come in and they read and they listen
and they watch and they talk to people
and they do all this stuff and so my
contribution is like
literally like non-material
to bitcoin and that's the way that it
should be for every single person
because that's the beauty of a
decentralized network it's like I don't
matter to bitcoin
right and you don't and nobody does
either because no one yeah come
everything comes back and it's the best
part about it like the idea that like No
One controls it
and nobody can be influential
over a long period of time or it
introduces risk so that's actually a
great question then too because I think
about this a lot because I'm like I root
for Bitcoin it's I'm so interested as an
innovation I agree with you even if like
The Conspiracy Theory were true and like
the NSA made it yo shout out to the NSA
that shit's fire but you know
and full disclosure like like I said I
don't really have money but my money for
crypto has been in Bitcoin and I have a
nice position in ethereum but bitcoin's
my main and that's all I own except
Chris Ibrahim made me buy like 20 of
polka dot when I was like hammered one
night and so other than that I but I
pretty much have bits and now you have
two dollars of it right exactly I I send
him a chart on our group text me Chris
and Dylan like every month where it just
I have the line on the date that he but
it was polka dot and I don't even
remember the other two that he had me
buy and it's just like like straight
down but it was funny anyway so
you know I want to see this do well and
I have my money where my mouth is in
that as well but I'm also constantly
questioning and I'm a realist about
things and I'm never going to get
religious about stuff just like you said
you're not and my my biggest issue
let's focus on bitcoin but I could say
this about all of crypto I just want to
keep it on bitcoin because it's the one
that is not
controlled you know it's not a company
there's not any of that [__]
when you have every government around
the world from
fascist a communist Democratic
everything in between
there's plenty of them to hate each
other some are at War but if there's one
thing that all of them have in common
it's this
if they do not have control over the
money
what the [__] do they control what how
can they be the Arbiter of rules if they
don't even control the thing that we
trade and so I've always looked at that
as the bear case for crypto that's
always in the back of my mind where it's
like
it's the bull case oh
I'm gonna ask about that in a second but
I want to paint this picture all of
those governments
whether you like them or not they have
power right and if they are if they are
incentivized to try to take something
down I do question if they're all
incentives to do it I do question minus
that guy in El Salvador I do question
our ability to
fight City Hall in that way and I wonder
it's like
you know I look at Bitcoin you said the
market cap right now is 400 billion
that's nothing
and that's and that's a bulk case right
but also like who's to say that they
don't own 60 of it at this point
well you can see online uh you know on
on chain via all the explorers and stuff
that nobody owns 60 no but in all
different like someone owns a half a
percent someone owns point two you know
what I mean
they there's probably more governments
than that have publicly acknowledged
that own it yeah um
but I don't think it's a material
percent right now could change
um
governments are made up of people
and people need Bitcoin
because ultimately the corruption of
money hurts people
over the long run
it also hurts corporations and it also
hurts governments
but it's a self-inflicted wound that is
necessary for the short to medium term
and so
you need a first principle solution to
the problem
and that's why you see countries that
don't have their own native currency
like El Salvador adopting it first
because they have the least to lose by
adopting this right because there's no
innovators dilemma if you will
because they don't have their own
currency he's like the cool dictator or
something
so to speak
and so
I think that every government eventually
is going to have to
participate because they're going to
need it
just like the people need it just like
the companies needed
just is going to take way longer than
people think
do you think that a lot of this stuff
that we're seeing right now like with
Sam bankman it's ironic I think in
August or September
I went I didn't even realize you had
done one with him I don't remember how I
found it but I saw it and I went to
watch it
and I think I got through about 25 30
minutes of it
and this was my conclusion
I said either I'm really really dumb or
this guy's really really dumb and at the
time I figured I must be really really
dumb like you know whatever
and then you see all this happen in
hindsight's always 20 20. but
you know there's not a ton of like
function in brain cells upstairs that
kid can probably do a calculus problem
here and there but that's about it you
know there's not
he would speak and like going back and
looking at before all this happened it
seems like he would just speak in
circles and a lot of some of the most
brilliant people in the world would kind
of be like well he's got a 40 billion
dollar company and yeah they are
accustoming assets for people so
okay all right cool but then it blows up
and to me you know you don't want to go
down the rabbit holes that people run to
with every goddamn thing as a conspiracy
and all right away but I do wonder about
where there are some potentially weird
connections that have to do with you
know the overall goal being to instill a
lack of confidence in the entire space
and therefore infect things like Bitcoin
as well from parties who are interested
in not seeing it success doesn't care
were 45 days 60 days after bitcoin's
right back to the same price it was
before
true right just like use the price it's
a free market asset price is truth
prices Express buyers and seller demand
and once again it bottomed
at basically
base for all intents and purposes like
the same
level where it topped the last run which
is a weird pattern that Bitcoin has
where just the last the new bottom is
the last stop and the new top then
becomes the next bottom or what very
weird but kind of cool you know it's
it's
again hindsight's 2020 but you look at
the last what four or five permutations
that's literally what it is so you know
in a way you could say it was exactly
what you're getting at it's like
agnostic to it what already was
happening was happening the price was
already way down
when this went down I do Wonder though
what else was was behind that kid and
obviously
Andy Bustamante was talking about CZ
obviously knows a thing or 10 about
China over there and that seems to be a
little questionable but you know that's
someone operating outside the system
that you're talking about too it's not
like we're talking about ooh bitcoiners
that went down here that's not what it
is these are guys who were you know they
had every [__] coin known to man
including their own [__] coin on there
and they just pulled people down with it
but you know I I think it wasn't the
best look to see some probably good
companies that maybe just got a little
bit
complacent in I guess like custying
their assets because this thing was
quote unquote too big to fail and again
like I said a million times hindsight
2020 but still it's like
you know
maybe some signs were there with that
kid
I think that's what people think now
yeah for sure where can we send people
to find the podcast trying to fire you
can go to my page
t-r-e-n-d-i-f-i-e-r on YouTube
friend of fire yep name's gonna be
changing to something simpler soon it's
a long story but you can also send
people to my Tick Tock which is at trend
of Fire and Spotify and Instagram and
Instagram's at Julian D Dory
all right and that's it I highly suggest
people go watch I love every episode
um you have a a collected group of
people who just
fire truth which I think is like the the
key component it's a great conversation
it's a lot of that I really appreciate
that man I I really admire what you're
doing here as well I've admired from
afar what you built so you know I've
seen you obviously doing this for
several years now it's really cool to
see where you've gotten and glad to be
here
all right everyone thank you thanks man